Joe Rogan and Shane Gillis need to stop
filming protect our parks on Mondays
because they've now both missed an
episode of kill Tony after getting too
drunk on
JRE in a body bag Shane was
supposed to be on kill Tony this week
but was unable to make it after getting
hammered with Joe Ari and Mark during
one of the funniest episodes yet ask do
they have a show to do tonight no we
don't not a Jamie Jamie I knew you going
to be a buzz kill dude try to R Jamie's
so nasty dude people don't know Shane's
got a good point
about relax listen if we can make Tony
hinchcliff sweat how I love how Tex how
you guys do it let me know the updates
like yeah there's no updates protect our
Parks is maybe the greatest tradition in
all of podcasting and although it is fun
to see the fellas come in hot to kill
Tony after a long day of drinking